Ayo what's happening man it's 38 Special
make sure y'all check me out on the
bootleg Kev podcast Trust
podcast special guest in here
my guy 38 Special what's happening
what's going on man I'm back man you're
back you got some shows in uh the
Southern California area Big Show a
catch Garden Grove new album is out for
people who don't know so what I like
about what you're doing with this album
you've done in the past is you put the
album out on your website early so for
the fans that are like
that want it now right you can monetize
that
right you know I get the people that you
know want to support give them a chance
to support a lot of people be wanting to
support heavy right don't even really
got no opportunity right you know what
I'm saying yeah because it's like you
can stream it but like what if I want to
do more you know so you know with this
right here I'm giving y'all the
opportunity to pay what you want you
know we start with a floor price at 38
but if you want to spend more you could
spend more and the people that spend a
lot Y'all Gonna Get You know different
perks and stuff you know y'all gonna get
access to like you know the the the
events you know the listening parties
and exclusive merch and stuff like that
you're gonna see all the incentives up
there when you go to the site it's at
even.biz well I just saw if so if
someone buys the album they can come to
the show in LA
definitely so they can come to the show
in LA and then there's an exclusive
listening seven shots vinyl too right
yes a vinyl that you get signed by me as
well yeah you know what I'm saying yeah
the vinyl turnaround's got to be crazy I
feel like it takes forever to get vinyl
made it was it got crazy when kova hit
right it's been better it's a lot better
now yeah it's back to normal and [__]
decent decent turnaround and [__] yeah
how do you top last year man you had a
crazy year last year I had a dope year
last year yeah this year gonna be crazy
yeah cause I got I got a lot of [__]
last year was my warm-up now I'm saying
like I only put out honestly I put out
like 17 songs last year but they but
they all you made them count yeah I made
them just count uh this year because did
you only put out seven shots in the
Harry fried [__] last year yeah yeah you
made them count though you're right yeah
right you know what I'm saying this year
I got a few things lined up like I said
I got Gunsmoke I just dropped uh me and
Conway got an album oh crazy okay yeah
the people gotta get ready for that is
it finished it's done oh man yeah that's
coming I'm gonna follow up after
Gunsmoke with that so y'all heard that
do you have a title for it oh you're
gonna need a lighter again aren't you
yeah I'm gonna need the lighter again
let's get this wonderful Jardine lighter
yes sir
so yeah that's coming the name of that
album is called special Machinery oh
yeah something serious special Machinery
yeah we on there getting busy and [__]
you know what I'm saying I produced the
whole joint me and my me and my guy
Jimmy Dukes he's a producer from out of
Buffalo we we produced the whole joint
oh and uh how many songs
ten ten oh yeah 10 joins me and Conway
dumping going crazy yeah and I feel like
last year Conway kind of like
he had a great year he did drum workfest
and stuff but I feel like he kind of
kicked back on releasing music at a
normal pace so I know this year he is
not playing yeah he's been loading up
him and Jay skis just dropped I know his
album comes out in April
when is do you know what date you guys
are dropping this uh for July August oh
[__] you know what I'm saying imma hit
him one more time one more solo before
the year out yeah you know what I'm
saying so I'm gonna give him three
projects this year I feel like you just
celebrated the anniversary of the album
with Benny and I made me feel like damn
time flies was it five years it was five
years man and uh we actually on a low
wheat and we in the studio right now
cooking you and Benny right now what
part two yeah and it sounds like damn
man it's surprising to hit a hunger that
we still got right like it's like wow we
still sound this good together and we
still you know I'm saying we bring the
best out of each other so one of my
favorite album covers too appreciate
that starting shot two is on the way
y'all y'all get ready for that man so
that might come this year too it's a
strong possibility if not it's
definitely coming next year yeah you
ain't playing bruh nah this guy's not
playing I'm in my bag right now you know
what I'm saying 100 man so
um what is the difference between doing
an entire project
with Benny which you've already done
you're currently working now and then
getting in with Conway do they have a
big difference in terms of just how they
worked it like like well yeah yeah it's
a difference because Conway is more late
than anybody well he's the latest guy
alive what you mean like he just be like
I'll be there at 10 but he comes in like
whatever you know that's my brother I
love Conway
but um yeah it's definitely different
and [__] me and Ben you know we was
recording for a longer period of time
right you know what I'm saying we've
been doing this [__] for together for a
long time yeah since like 0.708 right
probably oh six so you guys had a lot
more we got a lot more chemical
chemistry yeah of course you know what
I'm saying uh me and Conway we ain't
record as much but we still got history
and [__] but you know um the recording
process is still really like the same
though we still go in there and give it
our best yeah it's a very competitive
situation it's a good way the room it's
a great anytime like you know me and the
spit as it's a few spitters right that I
[__] with anytime we get together it's a
very competitive situation you know what
I'm saying and it brings out the best so
you know y'all expect to hear some great
[__] that's correct special Machinery
yeah I like that man that's gonna be the
hard ten records yeah any features
yeah we got Lloyd Banks on there come on
man yeah man I'm dropping so much just
news just yeah man I got Lloyd Banks on
the hill we got Pharaoh munch on there
does anyone ever tell you look like
Pharaoh launch a little bit oh we're a
little bit just a little bit just a
little bit if Pharaoh March didn't have
hair right I could see it
Pharaoh March is one of them ones though
that's the homie he's one of them once
yeah and you don't hear his name enough
when we talk about like the greats
Pharaoh March is one of them guys
yeah so you know that [__] is coming
back like you know upload it though man
upload it you ain't playing this year
hey so you're like you've gotten these
like huge cosigns from guys like KD guys
like Kevin uh obviously I already said
Kevin Durant who's a Phoenix Sun now by
the way
um LeBron James riding around listening
to your music like for you like when you
see LeBron is like
just a fan like what's that feel like to
know like arguably the greatest player
of all time is like extremely tapped in
that that feels great yeah yeah coming
from where I come from you know what I'm
saying it's it's amazing you know I'm
saying I'm not used to like I'm always
used to like being dope but like people
not knowing about it right it's almost
like those cosines mean a lot more than
like some of these industry cosigns that
you kind of feel like you need to be
like solidified right it's like [__]
that hey KD and Lebron are bumping my
[__] [__] what you think you know what
I'm saying facts and it's naturally
organic you know what I'm saying they
they they they feel the music you know
what I'm saying so that [__] that [__]
is beautiful I feel like I might have
seen you in the studio with KD am I
tripping nah you ain't tripping man you
ain't tripping no I'm saying we KD KD um
he'd been behind the scenes working with
me and ran on some things you know me me
and ran so so you know me and Rance I
mean KD we like you know got some things
cooking up y'all can expect
some things some powerful well listen
for people who don't know Kevin Durant
did have a record label back in the day
when he first was at OKC he did have a a
go at the music industry
um
is he trying to spin the block
and I wouldn't say trying I'ma say he's
spinning the block heavy yeah with
Ransom and 38 Special yeah I would say
that you know so did you guys sign to do
like a like an album with him no we just
he just we just right now we just you
know we just um
we just building
you know would you sign with Kevin
Durant I don't I don't I don't really
like even the word sign would you
partner with KD on the project I would
definitely partner are you guys
partnering on a project that's a strong
yeah that's that's definitely what's
happening we definitely partnering so
you Ransom Kevin Durant partnering on
the body of work yeah
wow yeah and Katie's got a great year
for this rap [__] so like yeah he does
how much input does he have does he help
him oh no yeah yeah four hands on and uh
you know I'm saying giving all a lot of
input you know he got a good solid air
you know we all come from the same
clothes what we like is for sure for
sure so you know you know uh that's how
that is you know and we just running
through reaching out grabbing up the
production and
that's amazing that's a big deal you
know what I'm saying so you got to come
to Phoenix now I definitely do you got
to come to the hometown man yeah post it
I'm supposed to be going out there
sometime soon and [__] go out we got
some great recording studios out there
that's where DMX recorded a lot of [__]
and Little Wayne did the card of three
out there and hey Z you know that we got
we got some good spots to lay down some
uh
some partnered albums with Kevin Durant
that's for sure oh no yeah I've already
hit but you got to come out for the
playoffs because you know we're making
the I mean we're gonna be in we're going
to the finals you know what I'm saying
as long as Katie's healthy as long as
his foot is okay and he don't slip on
the court anymore we'll be all right
word up do you okay so if you're if
you're working with KD are you
automatically like that's your squad
whatever team he's on hell yeah yeah
so your son's fan basically
right hell yeah I realize you gotta
realized like before before NBA started
supporting me and [__] you know I never
really watched Sports so you were never
a big Sports guy anyway never was a
sports guy I can't even tell you who
went to the Super Bowl last year
I don't even know who won a championship
last year you know what a year before
that no no that is a life I wish I had I
let so much [__] that I can't control
stress me out so much because I'm such a
sports fanatic and I gamble on so much
[__] I'm like I don't know any of these
guys I'm not playing in the games
but somehow my life is so wrapped up
into
it's like some gang [__] hmm like I'm a
I'm a [__] Suns fan like I've given
so much of my money to Phoenix Suns [__]
like if you were to go to my closet ran
I probably have a hundred jerseys it's
really sickening like but I'm just glad
that I've already bought three KD
jerseys they haven't gotten delivered
yet but I can't wait
shout out to the sons man I went to
Katie's house once
Freddie Gibbs during the pandemic had
his uh birthday there it was like a
little barbecue
and I was wearing a Sons Rex Chapman
Jersey and I got I talked with Katie for
about 45 minutes and he was giving me
props and
I was like I told him then I was like
hey man
would you ever come to Phoenix he had
just went to Brooklyn you know so how
like Phoenix I was like man look what
have you buddy anytime look it ended up
working out I'm gonna have to give you
my jerseys to get them signed though
no doubt yeah anyway well listen
um for you what is
what do you think the difference was
between
your last two projects because I do feel
like your last two projects
did kind of
um put you in a different place in terms
of I think recognition notoriety
even though you're a veteran even though
you've been doing this for honestly man
I think it's just timing because prior
to that I haven't released in two years
my last project came out in 2020 right
so I wasn't even expecting this kind of
response I felt like I was just warming
back up because I was kind of cold right
now I'm saying so when I put it up
you know it's just the quality of the
music and the timing you know I mean
that's really all it is I didn't do
nothing different
yo I'm telling you though man
you're one of the greats man yeah I
appreciate that no real [__] okay like
when it comes to this rapping [__] yeah
I'm knocking [__] down man and you'll be
so smooth I appreciate it the [__] you'd
be saying and the way you say it it'd
just be like okay it's not just like
some low-hanging fruit like rap [__] you
know because a lot of people get credit
for like being great rappers and like
they're great but like they're really
just saying like some really like
low-hanging fruit [__] you'd be saying
the slickest [__] where you're like
oh yeah like that's some life lesson
[__] wrapped up into some flake yeah I
appreciate it no for sure man is there
anybody out there besides you know the
immediate guys we'd associate you with
when it comes to like Benny and Conway
and those guys who you're just a fan of
from Far like who you're just like yo I
see what this guy's doing I might not
have worked with them yet but I [__] was
there I just [__] with their talent
their skill their music whatever it
might be
I like the little Russell kid he's dope
he's amazing and you guys have a crazy
independent hustle to pay what you want
right you know I like that kid um I like
the Finesse two-time kid too he's dope
too I think he's he's dope you know what
I'm saying like he's he's got very
entertaining raps I would say like I
haven't heard someone talk about Pimpin
in the in a way like that since Too
Short when I was a kid
and that's two times it's great but the
Russell I feel like you guys should
connect because you guys you've been
building this community with your fan
base for so long and I feel like he's
all about
the similar like staying independent
building Community with your fans giving
them an opportunity to kind of
back up uh what you're doing with their
with their pocketbook because like you
said man that streaming [__] is like
somebody can stream your [__] a thousand
times and it might not equal them buying
a hoodie you know what I'm saying and
it's like to them they're like all I do
is listen to this but it's like man if
you're really independent I think it's
important that you figure out ways to
monetize your fan base and give them
opportunities to support because they
really do want to support it's not like
you're taking advantage of your fans
you're giving like hey they want to
support they know what's up they know
you're not on a major label you know
what I'm saying right yeah hey we got to
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about the homies at mybookie bet on
anything anywhere anytime at mybookie.ag
and check this out if you sign up right
now with the keyword bootleg you're
gonna get a first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and that's not it
if you sign up with that keyword bootleg
not only will you get that first deposit
bonus up two thousand dollars but you're
also gonna get a free 50 000 sweet 16
bracket entry so many ways to win at
mybookie.ag I've been using them for
about 10 years now trust me when I say
I'm not co-signing them because they're
dropping the bag I mean that's nice but
I've been literally using my bookie for
the better part of the last decade to
put all my sports bets in to play a
little online roulette a little black
jack a little craps it's all there they
got the live casino they got so much
going on look March Madness is where
it's at right now you can get down with
that uh sweet 16 the elite eight the
NCAA Final Four all of it NBA season in
full effect baseball is about to kick
off get in on the action bet on anything
anytime anywhere right now with my
bookie so sign up at mybookie.ag use
that promo code bootleg right now for
that first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars and a free 50 000 sweet
16 bracket entry hey also shout out to
the homies at Bluetooth man don't forget
if you're dealing with erectile
dysfunction in if your penis is not
functioning correctly
it's a little flaccid you're trying to
get it a little hard a lot of hard
rather Bluetooth is where it's at a lot
of people ask me you always talk about
Bluetooth does it work yes it works all
right uh listen it has the same active
ingredient as Viagra and scialis but
it's in a chewable form all right it is
sent right to your door uh in a discrete
package it's a great thing man go to
bluetooth.com right now you use that
promo code bootleg right now you're
gonna get a month supply for free of
Bluetooth why not have some better sex
okay seriously uh there's so many other
ways you can get down too because they
just dropped the Bluetooth mint flavor
which is the same active ingredient as
Levitra just so many things we can do
here uh and look when you go to
bluetooth.com and you sign up with that
promo code bootleg they're gonna
literally send it straight to your crib
for free five dollars in shipping you
get a month supply for free now how does
it work one you don't need to go to any
doctor's appointments it's all handled
online with an online pharmacist you
don't have to worry about going and
sitting in a waiting room to go discuss
your dick with some strange dude or
chick hmm maybe you're into that I don't
know with that being said it's an
awkward situation all right if you're
dealing with erectile dysfunction all
you need to do is go to bluetooth.com
right now use the promo code bootleg and
you'll get one month supply for free
zero dollars right to your door your
wife Weaver never know it even happened
you know what I'm saying maybe you've
been a little embarrassed you're tired
of piping down that same old bra that
you've been sleeping with for the last
35 years put a little pep in your step
man take a blue tube use that promo code
bootleg bluetooth.com and try it for
free are you going to be doing um I know
you're doing like spot shows what about
like a full tour I'm actually on a full
tour right now so you know I actually
put it together uh I have about like 13
days and uh
right now we got about eight left you
know what I'm saying
so you know I I got a
gone and Grove I got La then uh
[__] DC shout out to DC I'll be there on
the third
uh buffalo on his eighth what's your
biggest Market outside of Upstate New
York like when you look at the metrics
and the numbers
uh New York City and Los Angeles yeah
because I feel like I I feel like when
you're out here you got the fans pulling
up with the vinyl you know swear you
know they're ready to get their [__]
signed like they ain't playing man yeah
now the fans show love man they they
support heavy
for you
I think that you're a high level MC
you're me and you are probably similar
in age in terms of probably the type of
[__] we grew up listening to what are
your like top five albums albums ever
not the best album but your personal
favorite
uh first I'm gonna say ready to die I
mean no pause life after death
but I mean some people like ready to die
because the nostalgic purposes nah you
gotta realize what my age Raider dials a
little before my time life after death I
connected with you know what I'm saying
so I would say life after death
mob deep Murder music okay
Jay-Z Blueprint all right
Nas it was written
great great Mouse album affirmative
actions top five not a song ever Dr Dre
The Chronic
the first one yeah I like that but West
Coast in there yeah because that was the
first that I remember the OG's like
playing that really had a heavy
influence on my on my you know and um
yeah that [__] was Heavy talk about you
and Ransom your guys's friendship your
partnership obviously you guys have
crazy chemistry together working on a
project partnering up with KD but what
is it about Ransom you guys I feel like
have each kind of had your own
interesting
route through the music industry but you
guys are both still here you guys are I
feel like each hitting your stride in a
way that like is dope to see because I
remember getting like Ransom a team [__]
like [__] my I might have been in high
school or at least like 18 or 19 you
know what I'm saying right
um but it's just dope to kind of see you
guys work together and I feel like you
guys do have similar come UPS in a way
you know
um talk about your guys's friendship and
partnership and what it is about Rand
that you guys click so well uh you know
man me and ran we we we're like in a lot
of ways and [__] we really do our own
thing and we really don't play the
politic game you know like this [__] is
really based on politics a lot of it
yeah you know what I'm saying so like me
and ran we both got the same attitude
and we [__] who [__] with us you know
what I'm saying we might we ain't going
to the events we're not going to be seen
we're not shaking too many hands we
really [__] with who [__] with us you
know that [__] hinder you in this it'll
also make you question
whether or not you're doing the right
[__] right it'll subconsciously also
influence the music if you if you
actually get too worried about
I didn't go to the rap caviar party for
the Grammys or you know all this
[__] you know what I mean right and
not to say that that's [__] because
I've been on the rap caviar podcast a
lot you know and
I from all of that now I'm playing
politics [__] you know I could see like
I was always a fan of ran but at the
point of time he stopped rapping and I
understood what he was going through
and at that point in time I realized
that it was a way for us to monetize
without having to play the politic game
yeah so and I went and hollered at him I
had one conversation with him and
he was back active with a Vengeance he's
been on his [__] he's been going crazy
for sure you know what I'm saying so
like since then you know we we we we
built a lot of
a lot of music you know I'm saying and
just built a strong partnership you know
what I'm saying
what does this album sounding like that
you're working on with uh Mr Durant is
it is it uh an EP is it a full project
is it like
honestly it sounded like some real
Soulful heartfelt you know what I'm
saying some real Soulful heartfelt [__]
right now we got we um we've been
working with the producer [__] oh yeah
big is a legend yeah bank is gonna
produce the whole album that's crazy
yeah so you know yeah [__] is a legend
yeah big is definitely a legend that's
hard yeah so that's gonna be crazy me
ran and Bing you know that's crazy you
know what's gonna happen you guys are
gonna put out this crazy body work and
now you guys are gonna have to drop one
off like once a year for for the fans
yeah we ready we prepared for that yeah
we prepared for that so much so much in
the works man hell yeah for you was
there what was the Catalyst to make you
kind of realize that
it wasn't about all the politicking that
there was an actual road to not being on
a major label not doing things a
conventional way but yet still getting
to the money get into a career yeah
that's all it was I like man once I made
a couple dollars that was it for me I
was like all right all I gotta do is
multiply this whatever I did to make
this amount started with me being able
to pay my bills off of music you know
that was like which is a big deal that
was a huge deal if you could support
yourself on your music you made it
right period and and you know it started
with like oh wow like and I would that's
when I kind of like you know changed my
whole lifestyle I said if I could pay my
bills off this I'm not gonna do if I'm
doing anything else I'm being greedy
yeah you're being greedy and you're
you're and you're jeopardizing them you
know what I'm saying like so so so
that's where it started so then it was
like I if I pay my bills maybe if I work
harder maybe I could obtain a lifestyle
difference yeah if I'm doing if I'm
doing enough to get the bills paid what
if I do a little bit more so you know
with that and with me making that my
only hustle that was another thing I had
to because you get all the energy in one
thing I had to put all the energy into
one thing I couldn't have no uh no plan
B see I realize like you know you get
what you plan for yeah you know so if
you if you like yo this might not work
I'm gonna have a plan B you're gonna get
the plan B subconsciously yeah you're
preparing for the plan for sure so
you're gonna get what you prepared for
you know what I'm saying and if you're
and you're gonna get what you what you
put into it exactly so if you're if
you're putting 20 of your energy into
whatever else it might be right and
you're only giving the music Shake 80 or
70 right you're cutting yourself short
right so that's basically was my
turnaround when I was like all right let
me let me get my all to this and I am
see what happens and see what happened
and each year I started you know
things start getting a little better you
know what I'm saying and that's
basically what it is when I like I said
when I made it my only source of income
I started educating myself on every way
I could make some money because that's
the only way I can make money now see
when it wasn't my only source of income
it was like all right I'm just talented
we're gonna figure it out we'll figure
it out but you ain't making no money
from nowhere else right you're not gonna
leave a rock unturned you got to turn
that you're like let me see what's going
on here how they did that how they did
this you become extra inquisitive and
that's that was like the whole turning
point for me when this was all I had did
you ever pay attention to there's an R B
singer um named Ryan Leslie definitely
he was doing a lot of monetizing his fan
base away from the major label system I
feel like early real early yeah real
early he was on it before you know a lot
of guys was
really you know he was one of the first
that was really like so the quality he
was doing that too where he had his
website quality Club I think where you
could go and like I think he was putting
albums out you could only buy from him
but for you you see the benefit of
having the streaming platforms
eventually get it as well of course
because you know
that's a whole nother source of income
and that's the game that the labels
place and that's a way for Discovery to
be higher for you of course because if
you have LeBron I'm not sure LeBron's
buying the album on PayPal or checking
it out yeah right so Ron's streaming on
Apple music of course to discover you
gotta have that visibility you know what
I'm saying so like I'm not you know I'm
not opposed to dealing with the
streaming sites you know what I'm saying
just want to make sure you get as much
as you can you ever chat with uh with
with Brian at all I ain't neat Braun yet
he never hit you the DM you just you
just woke up and yeah he just like oh
[__] he's just yeah and then yeah each
day posted me like four times that
shit's crazy yeah that was crazy yeah
yeah that was crazy you got to get him
out to the show man yeah definitely
that'd be crazy definitely I'm gonna go
to the game tonight actually playing the
Suns yeah you're playing the Suns I
might be there too oh wow I might take
my kids okay is Katie gonna be there no
he ain't gonna be there he's gonna be in
Arizona yeah we haven't hey we gotta
stop the interview real quick to tell
you about our family at Odd Socks baby
that's right shout out to Odd Socks
little Godfather sock right there
craziest licenses in the game the most
comfortable box period And if you go to
oddsoxofficial.com right now use the
promo code bootleg you're gonna get 20
off at checkout now they also got the
underwear going on these are some Street
Fighter draws let's pop these boys open
check them out oh yeah oh yeah a little
Chun Lee versus Blanco
what
amazing
do you like you who so much that you'd
wear you who on your feet
there's people running around out here
with goddamn hot Cheeto jumpsuits right
now so of course you would shout out to
Yoo-hoo they got crazy licenses we
already mentioned Street Fighter
Coca-Cola Pepsi yes they got the they
got the boat there they got Pepsi and
Coca-Cola uh they also got Scarface
Breaking Bad WWE so many dope licenses
plus their Odd Socks Basics line which
are these just kind of the normal socks
in my opinion are the most comfortable
socks I've ever put on my feet
I promise you you gotta go to
autotoxofficial.com right now and use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off your
entire order all right so go do that
oddsoxofficial.com also want to give a
shout out to our family at hardean
that's right Harding the craziest
dispensary you've ever walked into in
your life Hardy in Las Vegas you got to
pull up follow them on Instagram Harding
underscore Las Vegas you see the Hat you
see the logo shout out to the family at
hardean if you're in Vegas you got to
stop off you got to go pick you up some
weed it is legal in Vegas tell them I
sent you they're gonna take care of you
all right uh make sure you follow them
Harding underscore Las Vegas the largest
selection of previous cannabis I've ever
seen in my life the best smelling place
I've ever walked into in my life they
have a signature scent that's [__]
insane so shout out to hardine go follow
him Harding underscore Las Vegas check
out more info about them at
jardinlasvegas.com let's get back to the
interview
um what was the project working with
Harry Fraud because Harry Fraud is
another one of those guys who for
whatever reason
he's got classic music and I still I
feel like he's still underappreciated
when we think of the best producers but
like you guys delivered one of my
favorite items last year yeah I
appreciate that Harry is like amazing
man and real good guy man like uh
you know
he he seen the potential in me early
that's what really made me appreciate
him you know what I'm saying for him to
do a whole project with me early when my
you know I mean before everybody was you
know what I'm saying for sure so uh
that was dope you know he actually had
me come out to his house out in uh the
Hamptons and I stayed out there for
about five days he's doing well yeah if
he's got a house in Hampton yeah
definitely I was out there for like five
days and we recorded the whole project
and [__] we actually sat there I picked
out he he had a bunch of Beats to the
side for me I picked out probably like
four and then we actually dug through
samples for the rest from scratch all
from scratch that's why it sounds so
beautiful because he's sitting there
digging like oh no that's the sample
right there you know I mean that was my
first time working with a producer like
that like collaborating collaborating
like that you know what I'm saying like
you're helping find a sample like like
yeah like yeah now this stuff there you
found I mean I mean yeah you helped make
the beat then you know because we just
heard I mean I just heard Rick Rubin say
he doesn't touch anything he doesn't
know how to sample he doesn't know how
to he's there for his taste and he's one
of the greatest producers of all time
right right right right but you know
what me being yeah yeah hell yeah so
like that [__] that [__] was a beautiful
beautiful
situation and it came out beautiful man
you know what I'm saying and then you
guys just got the features after because
there's some great features we went and
got the features after
um yeah Harry reached out and got Jim
and Wiz you know I'm saying I went and
got bed and Ranch that I do got a shout
out to whiz man because you'll always
see whisp still pop up on like
independent rap [__] always that's big
man and like where's his Wiz like he's
like such a superstar where it's like
damn Wiz is on the 38 Special album
that's crazy I gotta hear what that
sounds like yeah that's fine man Shout
Out The Wiz did he did you obviously
he's up on what you're doing if he
decided to do it because he's not doing
anything I don't think you can pay Wiz
to get on the record I take that back
you could definitely pay anybody to get
on the record if the bag's right but for
the most part if you got a real respect
things if you see whiz jumping on
something it's because he wants to do it
right yeah so he must be you know tapped
in locked in you guys chop it up at all
or was it more of a hairy thing it was a
hairy thing yeah you know came out dope
appreciate that came out super dope
um now this year at least three projects
three joints how many songs is on this
new album
nine so I kind of like how you keep it
yeah manageable I'll be trying to tell
guys you don't got to give them too much
if I gave them 20 right you could do two
albums and even if I gave them 20 yeah
it's only gonna last the same amount of
time they they ain't gonna appreciate it
it's Gonna Last the same amount of time
what's good about your fans though is
that they consume projects right so I
think that like I agree with you eight
nine ten records is enough
right certain artists
to me it's the same thing with when I
think of scene when I see artists with
zero fans putting out albums
it's frustrating because I'm like yo
that's like one impression
you take that album and put out 10
singles if you don't have fans and then
let each one of those songs
equal a new impression you know what I
mean for you you have fans
they want your body and you're really
good at putting together bodies of work
not everybody so appreciate that who's
uh taking care of production on this one
you told me uh oh yeah so uh I gotta I
produced uh I only produced One joint on
this and uh I I went around damn man I
got Harry's on there okay I got a joint
with Harry uh I got a kid named Don
Carrera that I just
discovered fire and uh
[__] man
all right you gotta pardon me I've been
working on so much damn music you just
said you have like yeah
you know y'all got a part of me if uh
what about features on this one that's
dropping that's what's technically out
oh yeah so right now on this one I kept
at home team I got Ransom I got shayno I
got Fred the godson made rest in peace
now I'm saying and I got flea Lord shout
out to flea Lord man yeah I kept I kept
it all in-house kept it kept it easy I
like it man
um what are you aspiring to do with the
trust brand are we signing artists are
we trying to because I think you could
low-key do a lot of Consulting for like
some of these labels with some of these
artists who need help with figuring out
how to connect with their fan base and I
agree I agree and [__] you know what I'm
saying maybe when I get a little more
time on my hands and [__] you know I'm
saying I'll be more open to like you
know dealing with more artists right you
know what I'm saying but right now it'd
be hard to focus on me and
you know what's the distro situation for
you are you doing like straight disco
kid tune core you got a Distribution
Company so I deal with uh
I deal with I deal with a few different
I got a few different distro situations
I deal with uh Orchard I deal with
um Monarch which was E1 yeah I deal with
uh Empire as well shout out to Empire so
you know I I I I dealt with them all you
know I mean I all and you know
but yeah that's what I do I don't really
do the distro kid or the tune call
um
for several different reasons and [__]
because you know a lot of artists don't
know that
when you want to build come up
you know those platforms ain't gonna
give you the visibility
that you really need well they're not
gonna pitch you they're not gonna pitch
you right and that's a big deal so like
you know but also
LeBron James posting your song about all
the divisibility I mean so yeah so yeah
it's all about it's like it's really all
about your situation I just think I
think with distro kid I mean and I work
with Empire so I got love for Ghazi in
that whole team I just think that the
upside for digital kid if you're an
independent artist is the easy way to
pay people
because they have the split system so if
like he makes a beat and you could
upload all that you can upload it and
his account gets they got their own
account system in it and additional code
20 for the producer right 20 for the
feature whatever the [__] cutting the
guy who shot the video you know what I
mean and then everyone's getting paid
out and you don't have to worry about
that [__] but right but yeah no
teacher's own man um all right so we got
tons of new music on the way for sure
three projects
the album is out it'll be on streaming
services though win 331 Friday 331 331
if you buy the album right now you can
buy it for 38 or more or more whatever
you want to do in 5 000 with me you know
um
new album with Ransom on the way
definitely and Kevin Durant definitely
is Katie does he have a verse
not yet not yet he might pop up on that
though okay uh
Conway album special Machinery
definitely June July August maybe
definitely then another album and then
maybe a a new album of Benny yeah Jesus
yeah you ain't playing man yeah I'm
loaded
well look I appreciate you pulling up
man always
um go support this guy the new album is
out new album is out right now make sure
y'all go and get that hey can you give
me give me your favorite off of this new
album in your head what's your favorite
like couple of lines you have on the
album yeah
um
oh [__]
damn he's like I don't remember what's
on the album because I'm I'm recording
30 right yeah I'm trying to think uh
don't compare me to generic rap dudes
these [__] talking about birds they
never sing like they pterodactyls
fish my guy my guy boom yes sir